you know the good news about this whole
money thing is it's not rocket science
I was in a store the other night in a
restaurant the other night and um there
was by a store I guess is the best way
of saying it anyway this guy walks up to
me and says you know really listen to
your show but you say the same thing
over and over every day how do you keep
from shooting yourself after 25 years of
doing that I said well I don't have
suicidal tendencies to start with but uh
I like me enough to not do that but I
get his point we do say the same thing
over and over that's because this is not
rocket science principles don't change
the law of gravity doesn't change it
doesn't matter if you're Republican or
Democrat if you're communist or
capitalist the law gravity still works
there are some principles that are the
truth now we live in a culture today
that doesn't respect the truth much
because when you say oh I know the truth
and there's and well that's not my truth
as if you have a corner on the market or
something because if you have your truth
that I have my truth and they're not the
same one of them by definition is not
the truth someone has to be wrong and so
you know this relativism crap that's
floating around out there that some of
you waffle in all the time it's screwing
up your lives because you know you just
because you forget the law of gravity is
independent of your opinion there's just
no exceptions to that rule then I mean
yes you can you can battle back against
it you can sprout wings in a jet and fly
away on it but it still is going to take
effect there are physical laws and there
are spiritual laws and there are
mathematical laws and they're called
principles and they're how life works I
mean 100 percent of time if you keep
spending more than you make and more
than you make would be including people
giving you money or whatever else if you
taste put out more than you take in
100% of the time you're going to
financially crash yourself so why do we
do that crime I mean while we drive by a
car lock and go I can afford the payment
I'm so broke now I can't breathe but I
can afford the payment I think the toxic
smell coming off the new plastic in the
new car gives people brain damage it
does me I actually like the smell I like
a new car smell but you know it does it
causes you does not think anymore I mean
if you're a drunk why would you hang out
in bars if you're broke why are you
walking through the mall all the time
and you call that entertainment do you
think you're going to you know do you
think you're going to what is it up
spiritual test to see if you can walk
through there and not buy something so
the good news is personal finance is 80%
behavior it's only 20% had knowledge
because we know what to do we just don't
do it we know we have to live on less
than we make we know we need to be
saving for emergencies we know we need
to be saving for purchases so we don't
go into debt to buy things we know we
need to be investing for the future for
our kids college and for our retirement
we already know these things we know if
we live on a written plan that the use
of money is much more efficient called a
budget we know that we will more likely
achieve our goals when they're due
written down that's called a budget we
know these things those of us that got
any walking-around sense at all and that
includes you and me we know these things
to coin a phrase from the founding
fathers they appear to be self-evident
the it doesn't require you know rocket
science to to figure this out you don't
have to have a master's degree in
mathematics to get the idea that you
know 18 percent on your credit card is
stupid and the only thing dumber is
payday loans and we get that three
hundred eight hundred percent on a
payday loan is stupid and we walk
in there and do those loans anyway we
know you have absolutely no chance of
winning the lotto and you buy the ticket
anyway none you are 27 times more likely
to be killed in a car wreck driving to
the market one mile than to buy the
winning ticket when you get there that's
how bad the statistical evidence is on
it which makes you mathematically
challenged stupid the lotto ticket ISM
you know it's a it's a tax on people who
can't do math that haven't had any
concept of probability in statistics we
know these things a guy buying the
ticket all are gonna win but somebody's
gotta win stupid people phrases
somebody's gotta win haha stupid people
phrases you just wasted the money you
just wasted don't you give it to
somebody if you're gonna just give money
why give it to somebody needs it because
the government doesn't need it that's
who you're funding and then they give
some of it back to the public the
public's like woo you see what the
Powerball was and it's all you know the
little bubble head man or woman on the
TV news it's like would you see what the
Powerball is they're all excited to just
they fall right in the same crap so the
good news is about this whole thing it's
not rocket science if you don't have any
payments you have money if you make an
income you don't have any payments you
have money there money to be generous
with money to save and invest and you'll
end up with more money isn't that
interesting and so that's what we do
here every day live on less than you may
get on a budget get out of debt save for
emergencies for purchases for long term
investing retirement in college always
be incredibly generous those of us that
are
Jellicle Christians that starts at the
minimum of a tie the tenth to our local
church basic stuff y'all being on a
budget being out of debt living on less
than you make oh and there's a high
correlation between people who build
wealth and those who get along well with
others high correlation because most of
your opportunities come through other
people not from your little brain some
of you have a bigger little brain than
others but most everyone has a little
brain in comparison to the opportunities
that can be brought to you by contacts
who feel positively about you that's
where life comes from it's how it works
relationships so we'll continue to say
the same thing over and over every day
the good news is we do it through the
lens of your life in your personal story
which makes this show just downright
entertaining so we invite your calls a
toll-free at nationwide a triple eight
eight to five five two to five triple
eight eight to five five two to five
you